Chris Sims pro football live co-host
bleacher report NFL analyst former NFL
quarterback joins us here in the man
cave good to see you again good to see
you I like your haircut man you look
good I am looking younger I think it's
what are you trying to do yeah yeah
that's what the kids say all right we
were just talking before the commercial
ended and that is that we see how great
these kids are now in high school even
junior high grade school I wonder if
we're gonna have quarterbacks who have
15 16 17 18 year careers because it
feels like there's always going to be
another quarterback you can get at a
cheaper price yeah I think it's an
interesting conversation I mean cuz
we're in the era right now of the
franchise quarterback is bigger than the
head coach and you know he's really
second on the the pecking order to
really the owner but I I think I agree
with you just because of this really
football I think we're finally seeing
it's been the most popular sport in
America for the last let's say 3540
years at least and I think you're seeing
with all the specialized training kids
are doing at this day in age and it's
seven on seven camps and my little boys
eight years old and playing flag
football already and throw-in the ball
around to doing all that quarterbacks
are better than ever physically ready to
play more than ever
you know just jump right in you can have
success whether it's the Carson Wentz's
or the Russell Wilson's or you know even
Joe Flacco took his team to the playoffs
as a rookie all of that it's going to be
interesting too because we're seeing
that these franchise quarterbacks and
their contracts sir they're messing up
how you build a team and we've seen
teams built that can go to the Super
Bowl like the Eagles last year with
quarterbacks on rookie contracts and I
do wonder if that happens because this
year out listen I haven't studied the
quarterbacks coming out in the draft
this year but I know who the top ones
are and you're gonna have another four
or five first rounders again this year I
mean it's it seems to be it's going to
be a wave of guys every year that have
franchise quarterback superstar
potential and I think you know your
thoughts there could be could be
interesting going forward well that's
why I wonder if I like Derek Carr right
it's already on the clock in Oakland it
seems like that I
just can't imagine that he's going to be
their quarterback when they get to Vegas
a couple of weeks ago we had questions
about dak Prescott moving for cifra I
still don't know if he's a franchise
quarterback he's a bargain now yes but
after next year
is he a bargain at a hundred million
dollars yeah I would say no I mean as of
right now and I really like dr. Prescott
doc Prescott but I'm not paying him
twenty five million dollars a year right
now from what I've seen the last two
years and even this year and it's been
good don't get me wrong but yeah I think
that'll be interesting Derek Carr - yeah
you know this year I don't think they're
gonna give up on him quite yet I'll say
this because the offensive coordinator
there under Gruden is Greg Olson and he
was there in Oakland when they drafted
Derek Carr originally so I think he has
a little more backing there but next
year will be the big year like yeah if
he doesn't perform next year you might
be right he might not be there in Vegas
yeah I'd be interested to see what
Dallas and does that Prescott the
Cowboys that offense it's gonna continue
to struggle they need to go Seattle like
five years ago Russell Wilson
beast mode shotgun quarterback designed
and runs read options bootlegs
play-action passes their receivers are
not good enough they're drop back pass
game is not schematically creative
enough to where they're gonna win that
type of football game so play defense
play like the 2013 Seattle Seahawks I
think that's their best chance to win a
game how did everybody mint not
everybody how did most people miss on
Patrick mahomes um I didn't did you know
that just say you know well okay you're
you're you're there with me okay good
good good I like I'm the one watching
Texas Tech football against O'Brien
Stadium right Saturday afternoon I think
that's the the problem though right
there I think that was the first issue
when I first came out and made a video
like right after the NFL season had
ended and we're getting towards combine
time and I'm evaluating quarterbacks um
go okay here we go the combine I got a
catch up on the draft what the hell's
going on who would the guys and mahomes
is one of the first guys I turned on I
went on to bleacher report and broke him
down and made it we had a little video
of his highlights and I said this guy's
special like this is Aaron Rodgers Brett
Favre type special and I even had then
NFL coach friends like oh you're crazy
it's Texas jackets it's it's not he's
not ready to play in the NFL
was going man this is not the same old
Texas Tech this is not like he's
throwing a ten bubbles screens and has a
hundred yards off the bubble screen that
he hasn't thrown this was him making the
system it was him making big-time throws
and I think the emblem on the helmet and
their offense kind of hurt his overall
you know what do I want to say just how
great he was and how he was looked at
his perception was the word I was
looking for there as far as a top 10
quarterback well you're breaking him
down as a former quarterback I only
answered a phone call from a friend
who's an NFL scout who said keep an eye
on mahomes he's gonna be the guy moving
up the draft yeah and then I came in and
told the dance I said let's get my
home's on ya and they were like why I go
he's the guy coming up he's moving up
yes and it's going crazy here it was
special like when you watch this film I
mean first of all he threw 41 touchdown
passes and I believe ten interceptions
so it's not like he was like some
reckless gunslinger but that was the
label I know that's what's it's unfair
it's it was like you think Favre was a
gunslinger and and made bad decisions
wait till you get a load of this guy
right because he had like three passes
the whole year where he no he he took
some chances and it didn't look good and
but you know oh those three mistakes but
let's forget about the 97 other awesome
plays that nobody else in college
football could make and not try to build
on that and I think that's what Andy
Reid saw everything I know and maybe I'm
wrong I'm pretty sure he was the number
one player on the Saints board that year
there's no I was told the Saints we're
gonna take him exactly right and I think
Sean Payton's admitted it I know he did
when I had him on I said were you taking
mahomes and goes yeah you know I wasn't
there we were taking home right but
imagine that if you're Brees I know I
know
like you're bringing him homes and he's
ready to play now but the I still think
that the fact that Andy Reid said I got
a guy who's playing at a pretty high
level in in Alec Smith yes this guy
makes us completely different because
now we've opened up the entire field
right that's that's the point I think
that's the thing you see with great
quarterbacks in great offenses they make
you defend every square inch of the
field in Kansas City right now you know
through the first six weeks or seven
weeks whatever week we're on here is
like I've never seen a team that makes
you defend more of the field because of
ability to throw 70 yard bombs added the
fact that Tyree kills got such great
speed
you know the run game they got then it's
Travis Kelce underneath Kansas City's a
lot of fun to watch and they're not
gonna disappear from this you know
they're gonna stay stay the course and
be one of the best teams in the AFC yeah
I have concerns obviously about the
defense course and this is what I
wondered ya watchin last night with
Arizona's bad as Arizona yes right if
I'm Kansas City I call about Patrick
Peterson because now all of a sudden if
I get Patrick Peterson if I get you know
Eric Barry back ok now at least the back
end of my defense is pretty solid pretty
respectable exactly now all of a sudden
I got a little bit more well rounded
team yeah I would be but if I can get
Patrick Peterson and I am the Chiefs man
I'd certainly make it make a run on it I
I would certainly investigate that as
well because that you're right the
concern is the defense and especially
the back end they have some admirable
front seven guys with d4 just in Houston
Chris Jones is a beast in the middle you
know the middle linebacker play but yeah
I worry about them being able to match
up against teams like we saw in the
Patriots big moments so they have enough
guys that can go one-on-one and make a
stop and their corner play is below
average and I mean Arizona's got to be
thinking like come on it's they're the
worst team in football let's rebuild its
you're getting towards the end of
Patrick Peterson's you know prime he's
probably even on the downslope he is on
the downslope just to a degree still
awesome but I would I would try to get
something to build your team he just 48
right I mean that's actioned know it's
not ancient but if I can get him for
four years exactly right now you're
Kansas City and you got my homes in his
prime with that rookie contract and
you're in the Superbowl window right now
I mean they're in it don't don't don't
wait for three years from now when
you're about that the windows about to
close and then go oh let's make a move
and then you go oh man we only got one
year here left in the window you know
make it now do it another thing I
thought of with Jarrod Gulf and we love
to have that rush to your great or your
bad yes and Jared golf we did a
disservice you know Jeff Fischer doesn't
do a fence well no he does not
Sean McDade big McVeigh does offense
extremely well right you get the right
like you know this as a former
quarterback the
right system.if mahomes is playing in
Buffalo we're not marveling at Patrick
mahomes no it's it's exactly right I
mean the - Josh's who are rookie
quarterbacks this year don't expect
anything special from them there's no
way they got no chance to succeed I
don't care who you are playing behind
those offensive lines you know lack of
really top-end talent at the wide
receiver position
you know just there's too much to
overcome it's it's they're they're young
they're gonna make mistakes I see big
potential for both of them certainly but
don't look at their stat line and try to
judge them off that because that's not
fair
talking to Chris Sims joining us on loan
from Bleacher Report also Pro Football
Talk live with Mike Florio Bill
Belichick was asked about Khalil Mack
and could you
you know his clue Mack similar to
Lawrence and I'm paraphrasing yeah you
know Belichick I wouldn't compare
anybody to your dad
obviously played with LTE how much did
you know about LT growing up how old
were you at the time I mean I was one of
those kids that when I was like four
years old anybody would tell you I knew
every name and every number on every guy
on the team I was kind of the football
whiz kid like so when I was four or five
six years old I was very aware that
Lawrence Taylor was the best player on
the Giants and the best player in the
NFL baby
he didn't babysit you there's some great
stories you baby shame there's some
great stories that a lot I can't tell
the ones I do tell always that are the
funniest is you know Lawrence used to
come to the house very early in the
morning whether he was up really early
or out all night I'm not sure but he
would call the house and you know I say
this happened two or three times and he
would end up in the front front of our
house in the driveway asking dad for
clubs golf club golf clothes and dad was
gonna make him a you know an appointment
or a tee time at a dad's Country Club
and he'd go over there and that became
you a 2 or 3 time thing where you know I
could hear my mom down the hallway like
hi Lawrence yeah he's right here we're
home we're all asleep did he show up at
your house in handcuffs no he he there
are some stories like that out there I
think
that maybe in a team meeting like I
heard Carl banks tell this a few a
little while ago who showed up in a team
meeting yes right I think he was he
didn't get arrested it was something I
was having fun with maybe a companion
upstairs in his hotel with handcuffs and
they lost the key oh my god right but I
wouldn't compare anybody with Lawrence
Taylor I know there have been great
defensive players in fact when I said
this yesterday I had a couple of friends
who said man you're forgetting about
Mean Joe green and I said no what else
he created a position on the field yeah
an edge linebacker right an edge rushing
line by a game changer yeah a game
changer I mean like a guy that was 3040
years ahead of his time and you know my
dad always said it like this you know
cuz he goes no he goes lt's maybe like
one of five people that truly changed
the game of football and i was like what
do you mean by that he goes in in the
old days when the linebacker was on the
end of the line of scrimmage you said
hey back you block him and he ended that
they were like Joe Gibbs and the
Redskins right we can't ask her back to
block that guy so the tackle started
having to slide out there right yeah
where they would put a tight end over
there to also make it even harder to
double-team him so he had to go around
the edge a little farther but yeah
between my father and I've even heard
Bill Belichick talk about him before I
mean Lawrence is one of the freakiest
athletes in the history of football
he was 6-3 254 pounds dad saw him run a
four or five on grass and cleats so I
think you talked about that he also
wasn't necessarily a Khmer dup athlete
that's another thing dad says you know
you see Khalil Mak and them they're
lifting weights and like dad would say
he did the opposite of working out I
mean he didn't work out he was just a
naturally 6-3 255 pound
who had incredible speed and power you
something's happening with this Bears
Patriots game because it's only three
points yeah and I don't know how healthy
clematis right now I like the Bears a
lot this year me too I think they're a
playoff team mm-hmm are you sold on the
Patriots is the best team in the AFC
that's sold not sold on that but who is
yeah can't City prove they can go into
New England and play with him right I
mean yeah the Ravens can go in there and
play
exactly right but still feels like it's
New England I mean if it comes down to a
one game scenario and in there an AFC
championship game yeah I'm probably
gonna take New England I don't care
where it's out of even if it's in Kansas
City
you're right so but I think it's very
close like you know who's to say of that
game the other night wasn't in Kansas
City that the Chiefs don't win by three
points you know you do have to take in
you know home-field advantage in the
crowd and the ability for the offense
not to maybe do some of the checks at
the line of scrimmage because of the
noise and you don't want to you know put
too much on the offensive line
communicating and all that but yes it
seems like New England is raring into
form but you're right the Ravens are
scary I think the Chargers are scary to
the Chargers defense has caught up to
what their offense is now to have been
playing better the last few weeks I
would say watch out for them why I'd
like the Chargers I picked them to go to
the Superbowl they're better than good
answer city in my opinion because
they're more balanced and I think that
gets back then I think that they're
they're a better team than probably I
mean as a complete team they are the
pressure though that Kansas City can put
on you on the offensive side of the
football can change the way you have to
play as a team too so I think that's
where it's fascinating mean if Kansas
City gets the ball you know and this is
where they dropped drop the ball the
other night you know they can they made
a stop on the first drive of the game
and then didn't go down to get points
you know and you just when they can get
up first and then make you play oh you
got to play the catch-up game with us
they're right in their element and
they're gonna go alright let's have a
shootout and let's see if you can mess
with us and I like their chances most of
the time there what did you make of
Jalen Ramsay all of a sudden forgetting
how to speak after they got blown out by
down yeah the humbling experience for
the Jaguars I mean I love Jalen Ramsay
got it come on
but if he wins he's not shutting up here
probably not no you talked you talked
the talk you didn't walk the walk no
exactly right so and you know yes man up
take the questions say we got to play
better you know take some blame yourself
I didn't even like what he said about
Tyree kill a few weeks ago I thought
that was kind of demeaning it saves his
specialist:yeah I mean he's a weapon
like isn't that what a receivers
supposed to be last time I checked I
want my receiver to be a weapon
I mean Hills special it's anybody faster
than Tyree killin again I don't think so
like I think
gets to top-end speed faster than
anybody I don't know if he's the fastest
but I think he gets there there are a
lot of these guys would you want speed
or quickness and wide receiver oh that's
a really good question I guess speed if
you made me choose I would choose speed
just because the speed factor with a guy
you can throw outside right you could
just put him outside it's gonna open him
up on so many other routes because DBS
are always gonna go I'm worried about
him running the go route and then he
puts the brakes on and he runs the curl
route or he runs the comeback route and
all that's predicated on the fear of the
speed going downfield but didn't you say
Tyree kills the best receiver and the
best receiver in football right now if
you made me choose I'm taking Tyree kill
if you mind me you go hey you could
throw a go route to any receiver in
football go I'm taking number 10 from
the Chiefs you go you could throw a
slant route someone one receiver of hope
I go I'm taking Tyree killing the Chiefs
if you go let me have one of those
little you know invoke quarterback
shuffle flip the speed sweep looking
plays I'm taking Tyree kill yeah he
might not be the most nuanced Runner
route runner like some of the other guys
but he is a threat to score an 80 yard
touchdown on the field at any point also
with the attention that is you know put
towards him he opens up so much more on
the offense so you know he's fourth in
receiving yards right now out of all the
big-time receivers he's leading in yards
per catch he's tied for first and
touchdowns I think it's time you don't
have to agree with me that he's the best
receiver but it's time we start to say
he's one of the two three four best
receivers in football yes if I gave you
the Rams of the field in the NFC I would
take the Rams right now yeah I I have a
hard time going against it because you
know you talked about golf too and I was
kind of a golf hater
I'll admit that like last year when he
threw 28 touchdowns and seven
interceptions I said most quarterbacks
of football could have done that in that
offense what he's doing this year and
let's take away last week cuz he didn't
play his best game but he's doing this
year is when plays aren't served up for
him on the silver platter he's making
plays himself and that's the big thing
for me and evaluating a quarterback you
know everybody's covered their
protections bad what are you gonna do
like we see an Aaron Rodgers or a Brady
do every week and he is this year made
plays moving around in the pocket made
some big time through
was downfield and you know he's
definitely improved in in those areas
think Rogers needs surgery on that knee
I sure hope not man I hope this by week
get some healthy because I want to see
him closely just don't know if he's
gonna get healthy you know it's hard
especially when you're asked to do
everything on the team every week I mean
there he is on one knees second and on
team and leading rushing last week why
is he calling out his head coach why
doesn't something stay quiet I I don't
know see what I think he wants that out
there I think he's pushing the coaches
because they need new ideas in the
building man why can't I just go to my
head coach and say what are we missing
here we're not on the same page here and
so it's like John Merritt that the owner
of the Giants right holds it he has a
press conference or he's being
interviewed he talks about Odell Beckham
unit why not go to Odell Beckham and say
I need you to be quiet just play we gave
you this money yeah you know you're our
future yeah why does everything have to
be out there in front of it well maybe
in both cases they already did that it
just didn't get through that's where I
think of it I mean that's where I
thought okay especially with the Rogers
thing you know Green Bay Newt needs new
ideas in the building they're still
running the 1997 Brett Favre Green Bay
and I'm not even joking I'm dead serious
and you know Oh Joe Philbin comes back
in the building this year he's from
there it's so they don't even know what
they don't know and I think Rogers is
saying like I'm watching these other
offenses and they know how to feature
these guys every week and you guys are
just asking me to dance around back
there and make something happen that's
our offense and my career have have we
wasted more of Rogers or breeze with not
surrounding them with yeah now breeze
now has gotten yeah got it all going now
right yeah they got right Michael Thomas
is a great player but Rogers our breeze
of not surrounding them to cash in on
maybe another super yeah I mean you know
my thoughts on Aaron Rodgers he's the
greatest quarterback I've ever seen uh
so I look at it like that at least Brees
has always had one of the greatest
offensive minds around him and the
offense has always been given a chance
in Rogers case it's just had to be him
so much there's never been a run game
there's lack of creative ideas it's
really about his physical ability you
saw some of those throws
at the end of the game it's not like the
guys are wide open you're not like oh
wow great play design you're like whoa
there's another bullseye throw thirty
yards down the field on the back
shoulder of a guy perfectly placed
that's the most talented quarterback he
can't be the best because Brady has
Brady's amazing I get that I just don't
like that argument I mean yeah okay he's
more Decker it's a team sport game on
the line one drive I'm taking Aaron
Rodgers okay I'm not mad II yell at me
no I'm not mad at you people think I'm a
Brady hater cuz I say he's the third
greatest quarterback of all time and I
really love Tom Brady I just I would
play the game like Tom Brady if I was
the quarterback that's that was the guy
I wanted to be but the problem is you
picked your dad as second all-time
Rogers won your dad ruin the integrity
was gone after that and your younger
brother is fourth on there yeah I know I
know that damn bias that sends bias
great to see you Chris thank you for
stopping by
thanks for have all talk live co-host
Monday through Friday with Mike Florio
bleacher report NFL analyst and former
NFL quarterback for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]